um it's gonna be [ __ ] rob versus
lydia and lydia has been one of those
characters that has been discussed a lot
lately as being uh kind of like the the
secret boss that the new the new top
tier right and we've seen it results
wise we've seen it results wise but you
know depending on who you ask they all
have different ways of explaining things
on on why
in particular lydia is so good
yeah i mean especially in like high
levels like everyone in japan or the top
players have this uh have lydia her
recovery's great the way you play her uh
double actually said that he plays lydia
that was how she plays law just very
with punish heavy but wow big start to
the round for again with the three plus
four finds the corner and now make sure
look at that damage mark man oh man and
look his wall standing one his wall
splat move that that again does that is
so quick and there's so many ways to
bait that oh my gosh look at that he's
doing so well in this opening round
nice
double looking to come back here can he
do it
did not get the delay on the last one
doesn't matter
oh they both went for the low jab
round two they did they bought the same
thing but it was uh again that you know
what pushed first and he did reap the
rewards got that first round so let's
see double has that comeback factor the
hopkick lands
the jabs just to push for that corner
birds and the beast not that close but
the wall is in his side double now
trying to chip away
and again you know what he's so good
with that running knee that running
three just to create that space and just
push you but double looking to get that
first round on the board for him can he
get it though
nice whip punish one of the things too
that i i think is underestimated is
the way that
her hop kick can kind of hit out of
nowhere
her hop kick is is is very far and
different from a conventional hop kick
it goes automatically into screw but the
range that you could do it at especially
from a side step is insane
yeah and i think he did clip again with
that hop kick and uh back to the action
here again gets that third round so
let's see how double he'll dig himself
out away from this situation
no just trying to poke his way out f2
but wow big launch from again
oh and he's gonna get the wall here this
is gonna hurt what's the mix up at the
wall it's a bad position to be in let's
see how double is going to fight out of
here
okay
crouch jab just for just a bit of pokes
oh the red tape mark man it's happening
but oh just again putting that stop sign
in that holding the brakes
can double be able to spend this drive
one two says otherwise down the chamber
again gets the first round a good match
and you were just mentioning the the
move red tape that down back three if
it's on clean it goes into the auto
attack animation that move has a crazy
board has some crazy vortex
potential because depending on how the
opponent will react and how they'll get
up there's a lot of things that the
player can do like for example if they
react with a get up kick right or if
they roll to the side or if they get up
straight to kind of block in and guess
on the mix-up afterwards there's so many
things that lydia can do and it's i
think one of her best
uh moves for making a comeback
especially with rage the amount of
damage that it does for the unskilled
hit with rage towards the very end the
red tape is such a crazy and a scary
move and complimenting that is of course
things like the hop kick her down
forward one and even the political storm
it covers so much ground but man her um
her low as well the down back four the
tracking and homing low that move is i
think really really really really good
obviously it doesn't crush because she's
still in the standing position
afterwards but the the fact that it can
catch you
and kind of restrict your movement is
something that cannot be underestimated
yeah you just mentioned a list of why
lydia is so dangerous right and we only
saw just a glimpse of what uh lydia
could do with double we haven't seen
much of the political storms we haven't
seen that much of her her jab and poke
game the ff2 because against defense has
been showing so let's see if uh double
will be able to you know just show
why lydia is so dangerous
oh man
he is putting the mix though on double
let's see what he does
it was really interesting there had seen
that sequence and the way he's kind of
controlling here and her running one is
man if that hits it does so much damage
because of the follow-up
oh speaking of a lot of damage
yeah it gets that jet kick and all the
needs to get the first round wow
again has been all gas no brakes so far
with this falcom run
there's that running one you're talking
about and look at that damage
a little slow there on the follow-up
oh there's a sidestep pop kick that is
such a killer move
the way that it's used there one for the
red tape
oh looking to close it out that should
be it
yeah great stuff from from double
sigh of relief on his side so again you
know it's still undeterred still very
determined
shipping away and you gotta when you
talk about falcom ram you gotta talk
about the range and you gotta highlight
how he can just keep you at bay with
that yeah that that jet kick his his
three oh and just can mix you up with
that hell sweep too
charge it up to the wall
the guard break pressure as well that is
so real especially by the wall because
you're gonna be looking out for certain
things right you're gonna be looking for
the standing three and whether or not he
changes the extension but as soon as you
realize it's too late you're going to
get guard dressed at the wall well uh
big counter at three plus four
and that's gonna be it i
i felt that mark man that made yeah that
three plus four
again
since this is still a best of three
we're still not a winner's finals double
needs to yeah just pull something out of
the hat here that's the punish oh no
range on that down back two
yeah that down back one that down back
two is so evasive it's a great move
especially on hit it puts her in a
negative one state against her opponent
which doesn't sound like it's the
greatest but
because of her her options that she has
it is actually really good
and and you gotta remember [ __ ] rob
doesn't have the best sidestep either
true
no that was a little too close or yeah
for
again to be able to try to make that
comeback so let's see if they will see
more down back twos come from double
nice punish on that nice kick again
rising two let's go double
and she gets so much wall carry it's
crazy there's a delay hit on the last
part of the string
how is he going to deal with it back to
the wall this could be scary
oh the red tape with some red tape i bet
is it though oh he's trying to push
towards the wall again he's gonna have
to yeah put his defenses up but no
grants double some rage
final seconds here we're halfway through
the last match the last round
is so important for double to get oh
oh wow turns it's a triangle trick and
again moves on go for it
he ducked he he thought it was going to
be the high extension and he ducked he
went you saw it he went for the wall
setting too and then he got popped in
the face